em relação ao sentimento da... Da espiritualidade, assim, porque como foi uma imagem de cachoeira de natureza, especificamente, tem uma conexão com a minha religião.
Então, ver aquilo foi um pouco emocionante.
Foi tipo assim, ok, é tecnologia, é sempre por isso que eu perguntei se era o mesmo vídeo.
Não foi uma coincidência do tipo de dizer sempre o mesmo vídeo.
Mas, obviamente, para mim esse vídeo toca diferente.
Acho que a experiência aqui é muito subjetiva.
Se uma outra pessoa que não tivesse a mesma religião talvez pensasse diferente.
Para mim veio uma emoção, sim.
Acho que assim, eu fui... Todo mundo sempre muito simpático, sempre muito perguntando.
Não teve uma coisa muito...
Não me senti...
Não tenho outra palavra para usar.
Não me senti no açougue.
É isso.
Acontece muito em muitos hospitais simplesmente verem como um corpo, uma máquina que está ali para ser consertada.
Então as pessoas olharam, perguntaram como eu estava me sentindo.
Teve a preocupação quando eu falei que eu estava com espada e tal.
Então teve toda uma...